Vanessa you've always moved me as an
actor you touch some cord some heart of
something which we all recognize an
essential humanity and essential
femininity it seems to me you search for
and distill for us moments of truth
always listening to or leaning on or
letting the energy the moment of that
truth allowing it to have its birth any
actors gift is a mystery we the audience
know we feel something other is being
transmitted we know when we receive it
there is I think the skill of acting and
then there is the essential spirit of
the actor Vanessa skill is extraordinary
because it is rooted in her soul her
imaginative inhabiting of a role is
conceived considered executed with craft
and artistry fundamentally at one with
her soul people asked me people have
asked me and are asking me what it was
like to direct Vanessa Redgrave they
usually under the impression that
directing is something you tell people
what to do I believe that the best union
of actor and directors are sort of
paired to do a dance of energy and
understanding when we work together you
came with such a clear understanding of
the humanity of Volumnia it was quickly
obvious to me that I just had to be as
enabling as I could try not to say
something crass and make sure with Barry
Ackroyd's help the camera was in the
right position and make sure that you
were in focus there is one lis camera
shot of you slightly soft which drives
me crazy
but this technical imperfection carrying
your perfection has a kind of magic it's
your magic
I'm going to go off-book now because I
want to describe to you a moment of
working with Vanessa which says it all
for me there's a scene at the end of
this story of Coriolanus another comes
to plead to her son and it inherent in
the scene I suppose is a kind of
formality he is sitting there she comes
in and the stage directions and the
texts indicate that she kneels it was
about five or six feet away a new very
sweetly said yes yes I will I'll try
that and you got down and you started to
feel your way this is a rehearsal and he
said I don't think I think I want to be
closer and you got up and you then
decided to kneel right in front of me
and put a hand on either of my knees and
looked at me and it was the most
extraordinary moment because I had never
anticipated that level of intimacy
starting this scene and you could feel
in the room that everyone watching even
Serbian crew who couldn't understand
English there was some extraordinary
inhabiting of a moment and it to be on
the receiving end of it as an actor but
for everyone involved
we witnessed you distilling that truth
and you went on doing it throughout the
scene so you discover in in this role a
profound union of intimacy and Meryl
mentioned the word intimacy human
intimacy through the language of
Shakespeare portraying a woman whose
sense of duty is severe but whose
maternal pulse allows us an
understanding you show us this your
great gift to us is your I believe your
human understanding your compassion your
sense of princess
your sense of the universal and of the
immediate and the capriciousness of the
moment and your humor to your love of
your family and your exquisite dress
sense makes you in my eyes simply the
greatest
you